foreign
okay
oh I I was supposed to play D6 before
castles I forgot that's the line I
looked up
yeah I hate playing against in Smith's
love system it's actually a super
annoying line
if you want to know like how to annoy
Kings Indian player just play The
Smith's love
no actually I have not been playing
Sasha much because he's been outplaying
me like very consistently in our last
you know in our last handful of matches
like I've been getting just squashed
oh
oh
Boynton extreme it's a streaming of
Jasper's Jasper string as well and Dean
DNA streaming and DNA it's kind of fun d
d I never seen Street Scene title two is
you know important tournaments you know
94 I want Bishop F5 okay let's throw an
H6
maybe we'll go Rook a to d8 to prepare
G5 and then D5
maybe I should retire 3100 on the nose
it doesn't get any better than that
is not very good
don't really think it's anything that
special
after replaces the spine with G5
syncope light is going to be a little
bit Furs here
I was watching when mirror stuff closer
it's
closing goal and
tournament
um
oh the dance at the end at Diana yeah
nothing better than that
might be one of the funniest phrases
ever uttered in like the world of Chess
nothing better than that
nothing like there's literally nothing
that's better than that than me raging
breaking a webcam
what's also funny is I didn't even have
a webcam I was literally using my
computer camera and my computer just
froze
oh Dan fractured his hands oh did he had
nothing better than that
God that was honestly one of the most
infuriating rumors that I was ever like
had to deal with
the whole like fractured my hand thing
maybe bishop fade first made sense
um Bishop f8 B5
let's see what do we do now
how do we do this
okay let's start by tying down his Rook
oh but he's got I forgot he had Bishop
D6 here
yeah I don't think I'm gonna win this
I don't think I'm gonna lose it either
but
that leaves a particular result that we
do not like
yeah what am I doing why did I do that
foreign
really
Sasha
no I don't think I'm gonna
I would go for it if the time situation
were reversed I'm worried I'm gonna get
flagged here
and Sasha's just so good at end games
he's like so good I don't like yeah
I'm gonna go for it
no why did I do that
I don't know if this works or not
okay try
gosh she's so solid now it's like he's
genuinely very hard to beat
why is this freaking thing I never look
up never look this up for some reason
this this goddamn Ford Knox variation is
giving me nightmares
yeah and I always fall for the C5
nonsense
we always get this same position in this
Ford knocks variation
yeah I've lost like a
crafted of rating and I haven't lost the
game
no but I'm not even going to win this
like this is this is basically an
unwinnable position black has no
weaknesses
I have to sack on F7 somehow
I have to create some like tactical
chances on the king side that's really
my only chance
Sasha doesn't really miss tactics
anymore so
Queen C6
what a strange move okay wait
but it works
D5
right D5 has to be good for white now
let's try it
what does he see here
how can the snap between D6
really oh and it just works
hmm
let's go here
take take here
it's complicated you can also go check
and then take on F7 take
Queen G6 King f8
I can't calculate that fast it's just so
much faster than me
I mean look at the speed with which he's
defending
like an insane position
Queen G6 and D6 looks pretty appealing
the indigo's bishop takes
I don't have time
no I'm at a dead end
let's go here
oh my gosh G4 I mean H3
okay Rook D3 Maybe
you defend this so fast
I don't have no time
I want to go 95 and trap his Queen
he can probably give his Queen away for
a bunch of pieces and win
too
lightning lightning speed
blunders
that was a terrible move
at the end
still I mean the pressure he puts in
these in these types of situations is is
wild I'm curious if I actually was
if this oh this is winning yeah
we can see two best move
best move
oh 96 of course 96 is the move
yeah this is still winning but
I was just panicking because I had no
time this is correct this is correct
this is correct
this is inaccurate
this is inaccurate
this is correct
this is correct
yeah I mean I played pretty well
let's try to win this one
okay another samish
Queen C2 interesting
thank you Jesus
yeah I've prayed
okay somehow he knows everything here
yeah I heard some good things about him
it's probably Jesus
foreign
a very important detail here
that 95 is meant with Bishop C5 for
pinning the The Rook so I have to give
away
the pride of my position my King's
Indian Bishop
no I only watched the US
I only watched the US in World Cup like
I watched US versus Netherlands on
Saturday
yeah kayconos right
I only watch America
I don't care about any of the other
countries like Europe the country of
Europe
name Rod the duchies are going down
because the American's best team in the
world
shame on you for thinking otherwise
we predicted a move girl
hell yeah
right
yeah ballistic is very impressive any
place chess which is kind of cool
I don't know how many people knew that
but he's like 1400.
yeah Christian pulisic is like 1400.
okay am I losing probably
there there
takes B5 F4 B6 F3 B7 F2 that is winning
okay let's try it
I'm sure he's already calculated it a
long time ago though
no it's true
wait what up here
like oh my gods
what if I just go here
what
oh my don't tell me that works no come
on
that's absurd
it does work oh no
or does it
I can't believe this
it's actually Wild
could I even can I even pull out a draw
here
I think I can
Sasha just comes up with these wild
ideas
I don't see a win though I mean I can go
rugby five Rook G5 but I have no time
oh it is winning oh it takes ah Rook B5
Rook B7 and F3 oh
yeah this is why I'm not on my right
mind right now
yeah Rook B5 and Rook B7 and F3 I didn't
see that at all
I forgot I could even eliminate the pun
yeah that's disappointing
no I saw Rook B5 Rook B3 I just forgot
forgot about Rick takes piece
I think it's p7
yeah I I I've calculated so well
initially in that end game as well
only to ruin it at the end
okay let's go here
I I think I get the most of that comment
like by far of any streamer
like it just
I think the vast majority of people just
think I'm high
all the time
on just like a Thursday Thursday
afternoon
police is 20 is 1400 on chess.com I
think
no no no
does it matter
enjoy
littlest TV
sure to get some doordash
let's go Bishop E5
suddenly this is looking pretty decent
for white
let's see if I can put together a nice
positional game here
E40
here
okay we have to try it
thank you Davina
I'm fine thank you
huh
really really
what if I take with the Knight
um ah he's got this move of course
of course
yeah and it does not fall for anything
here
okay let's try this
wait what
can't I take
oh shoot he wins the pun
wait wait a minute
oh
loses the piece
wait wait wait
I need to finish this off this will be
oh
oh he has no checks let's go
but I have to win this for 23 seconds
this is not that easy
thank you juho for the subs
okay we're just gonna inducevang
oh this is actually super cool too he's
in zugs Wong
he has no Queen moves because of mate
and if he goes G5 I can trade Queens
vamos
foreign
think the move is C5
black is better here
there is a move here that I forget what
it is it's a very rare move the computer
recommends
what what is it come on
um
I don't remember
okay I'm gonna try this
it's Bishop H6 maybe another Bishop H6 I
think is the main line I don't know
I don't I really don't know
now I'm worse but what else is new
oh shoot he has this move hmm
that one I also forgot about
but I am
yeah we can't get going to this against
him I have to look this up
this thing is horrible
foreign
lets me get my Bishop out
okay okay maybe
thanks
should have gone H4 of course H4 and H3
but it's okay my positions
tenable
my position is tenable
somewhat tenable
let's try to undouble the Pawns
walking into C4 a little bit but
thank you tree potato
oh [ __ ] shoot
um I sacrificed it okay it doesn't take
it
I'm gonna insist on not defending that
pawn
I'm gonna insist on it
to out of stubbornness to pretend that I
in fact did sacrifice it
yeah of course Sasha as usual
this is not mine to draw
I have Bishop H2 if I want it
Rook c80 goes Bishop E2 I guess
I really don't know what to do here
I'll always defended I didn't see that
foreign
gotta be very fast here
I'm threatening Bishop F4 and it's not
easy to defend against that at all
okay I think I can flag him now
yeah he panics
Sasha panicked there
no but he was already lost I managed to
put enough pressure on him there to uh
really Grease the wheels there
good stuff
it was a nice game
thank you Thomas Martin Knight
okay what do we want to play
let's go G3
you know but this I always go for this
line against him and it's never good
I did that again
oh
I'm always always losing this line
this is insufficient compensation that's
really the core of the issue and
probably I should have gunned you before
okay go C5 anyway
interesting wait a second what if I take
there's no way this is that good for
black
hmm
okay let's contemplate this for a second
so
ah crap there's an annoying line there
um
I need to find a very accurate movie or
else I'm going to be lost
and I might be lost anyway it's just
yeah somehow he defends everything
okay I think I have to go Rook D4
I really don't think I have a choice
wow he gets out doesn't he I don't trap
him
okay here
I guess he goes Rick d8
takes it
or see it I guess I trap tonight
okay now I think it's already not wait a
second wait a second the Knight is now
trapped isn't it after Rook B3
oh shoot
I'm suddenly trapping his Knight
wait does this work though
the point is Rook D4 there was Knight C5
and it intercepted the bishop but here
but here
I go Rook D1 on the next move
yeah okay but now I should be I'm
actually gonna take probably with the
pawn here to prevent him from making
past spawns easily
this is far from Easy by the way
far from easy okay let's fix the pawn on
a dark Square so that we can attack it
with our Bishop
I mean it is winning handily
okay we I think infiltrating makes sense
Rook D3 I'll go King F2
and I'll go for the front for the direct
attack on G7
okay I can also trade and that's
completely winning
probably Rook C7 though simpler
isn't it and Rook B7
yeah okay but now I think I should take
and go here
and take
there there there there there there
and A7 and I win okay
yes
that was pretty good technique I think
hmm I'm not too worried about E3 here I
think this is just dead equal
I have never done an IQ system nope
and I have absolutely no
interest in how we're doing one
sorry not interested
deeply apathetic
FIFA I only watched the us as I said
earlier
I think there have been studies
with chess but I'm not sure you can read
the academic literature I would make I
would do a search on academic literature
I'm not
as an expert in that field
I would venture a guess and say that
most chess players are on the ordinary
side
and the correlation is probably a lot
less
than people think it is
yeah exactly
no we refer to football as soccer
I think I'm slightly better here again
problems just okay
distribute not every yeah and that every
piece needs to distribute the code
vaccine
I like how some people in the YouTube
comments are like
you know like I
it's just been as a joke I I don't mean
to like pass judgment on the efficacy of
the vaccines
foreign
people take things so seriously
J flash it's twitch we absolutely do
I don't get the obsession with IQ I just
really don't understand it
foreign
concept of intelligence is very
interesting but it's
hasn't been shown like over 50 years ago
that there's like a million different
types of intelligence
and it's undoubtedly true like
you should know that from your own
experience with different people
come on
like I yeah like I I find athletes to be
some of the most intelligent people in
the world and they're like particular
area
I have no time I need to focus
crap
no freaking time
see that's the thing with Sasha now he's
like
always pressuring me on the clock
weirdly enough
where where is it used to be the
opposite
thank you Sasha bortick for the raid
let's do it in my old age that's right
okay let's continue with Mr stemov
it's been a while since I've played him
now so I'm really enjoying this actually
welcome everybody
welcome all
yeah here comes Sasha with his attack
foreign
okay
um
F3
I guess I can play F3
this is very manga s
this is deeply deeply monk ass
so you have E4 something ridiculous like
that
I'm like I made it here I'm pretty sure
yeah I mean Alexander is like
huh
super common
hmm
over here
I want to go Queen C3
yeah now I thought maybe takes and takes
probably a mistake but I think it's the
most concrete approach
and
then
I don't know 95 Rook F1
there they're there
I was really hoping he would not find
that move
and that move
foreign
wait no this has to be totally winning
yeah this is over I'm mating him I
managed to navigate the complications
there pretty successfully
which is um
pretty awesome
okay he's gonna play the fianchetto
yeah this is a line that I need to look
up also because he plays this now pretty
often
okay I shouldn't have done that probably
I should have gone of course I should
have got any six naturally but
hmm
oh God look at the time
Lucario is good at any level
I wanna
I wanna preserve night Knight C5
for a rainy day
okay now we need to navigate this very
carefully
foreign
wow
no no no no that was a terrible move
I walked into the potential pin oh God
I need to be very careful now
oh no
why am I choking this
totally choking this
foreign
foreign
I pulled it off but that was not easy
oh
I was definitely totally winning but
then I somehow like I missed that idea
the double exchange stack was actually
super practical
the double exchange stack was was very
annoying
okay we're playing a lot of Dutch today
okay let's play a slightly different
system this time
I'm gonna try to go E4 at some point
later in the game
maybe I can also go queenside Castle in
G4 that does look very risky
yeah
I think I'm gonna go kingside let's not
let's not do anything crazy
so so would I be bingy trust me
I'd love to appear on either and I will
accept heartily if the invitation
arrives
foreign
Magnus earlier I'm pretty sure he's
playing he's watching football
I don't really get E5
probably what I'm gonna do is I'm going
to get going soon because I I'm still
I'm I'm still really really tired but I
will definitely be back a little bit
later for more Blitz in the speed run
so that's going to be the plan we're
going to do a two-part stream today
but I need to eat also
okay let's go 96.
not too late no no because I'm still I'm
still under the like I it's it's weird
how little energy I have like I'm
so let's go
here maybe
here
here's another double exchange sack by
Sasha
foreign
one threatened
this
is very slippery
okay let's cut off the circulation here
I'm up like a thousand pieces here
and it's still hard to win
but let's just go Bishop G5 that should
be enough
yeah this is totally winning
we have the same number of pieces that's
true all right GG Sasha